[Music]
they're the deadliest thing on earth
they suck your blood and spread disease
killing nearly one million people each
year
are we talking about vampires
lions
gorillas
actually none of these things
we're talking about mosquitoes
are mosquitoes really this deadly
what would happen if they all
disappeared
would humanity be better off
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we killed all mosquitoes
it may sound unusual that a little bug
could be this deadly but it's true
mosquitoes spread diseases like malaria
yellow fever and the dengue virus
they do it by biting someone who has a
particular disease and then biting you
and injecting their saliva into your
body
the saliva then enters your bloodstream
causing you to contract whatever virus
or bacteria that the mosquito picked up
and it's not just humans they affect
either
animals and farm livestock all around
the world suffer greatly from mosquitoes
just a single bite can be fatal
so how do we get rid of these bugs
well first we have to figure out exactly
how many mosquitoes there are in the
world
that's incredibly difficult to find out
it's estimated that there's 7 trillion
of them
in alaska alone
yeah that's right alaska due to global
warming and ocean temperatures rising
mosquitoes can live in places like this
and around the world there are trillions
of other mosquitoes
there's a number of ways we could get
rid of them
bats eat mosquitoes without any risks
they can eat 600 mosquitoes in an hour
so if we had enough bats in theory
they could effectively wipe out
mosquitoes all around the world
but then how would we get rid of the
billions of bats in the sky
okay maybe that's not the best idea
another thing we need to understand is
how mosquitoes reproduce
you may think they're sucking our blood
because we taste good and they're hungry
but instead of feeding themselves
they're actually doing it for their
larvae so if we somehow got rid of all
our blood and
wait
yeah that's not gonna work either
instead of these options we may need to
release genetically modified male
mosquitoes
ones that don't bite and can only
produce sterile offspring
it could take several decades but with
enough of our genetically modified
mosquitoes producing sterile offspring
mosquitoes would eventually be
eradicated so now that they're gone
what would happen next
well millions of people wouldn't be
getting sick and dying each year
you could enjoy being outside in the
summer without any fear of being bitten
and animals would be much safer as well
that's right not many bad things would
happen if we got rid of all the
mosquitoes
what about the circle of life and all
that
don't mosquitoes contribute to the food
chain
sure some birds bats and frogs eat quite
a lot of mosquitoes
but they're still not a hugely
significant part of other creatures
diets
and these animals will survive without
mosquitoes
and although mosquitoes do pollinate
plants it's not significant enough to
justify keeping the species alive
but still is getting rid of mosquitoes
the right thing to do
after all we would be getting rid of an
entire species
we should keep in mind that there are
thousands of different species of
mosquitoes
but only six of them bite us and spread
disease
not only that but there are some
theories that mosquitoes may help to
protect the amazon rainforest
that's because they're so deadly and
annoying to the people trying to cut
down the rainforest that at times the
bugs actually prevent them from doing so
and let's be real for a second the human
population is growing incredibly fast
maybe mosquitoes are helping us to keep
our population in check
wait what am i saying this would most
definitely be a good thing there would
be less disease fewer people dying and
very few negative consequences
but what if instead of mosquitoes
getting wiped out half of earth's
population did in an instant
well that sounds like a story or another
what if
[Music]